foreign
the music and dance
the color
and the mysticism With A Touch of Magic
Susan Middleton an American voodoo
priestess ranks high in the hierarchy
I feel those Spirits many of them are
associated with natural forces like the
elements water fire Earthly air and lots
of other things I mean is fascinating
she says her religion is widely but
deliberately misunderstood
diabolical forces it's a cliche largely
driven to Hollywood
but it's a very deep spiritual tradition
that's ancient all of our cosmologies
originated in Africa so it needs a
marvelously
um ceremonial culture with many many
divinities
Voodoo has its roots in West Africa with
Benin considered its origin
from where it's exported to the rest of
the World by slaves taken from Africa to
walk on plantations
and it's back here in West Africa that
worship us from all over the world
gather to celebrate every year
Benin office
Heritage and identity this Festival has
been celebrated for the past 10 years as
a celebration of a religion and ancient
religion followed by millions here in
Benin Republic and millions more abroad
especially in the Caribbean
[Music]
a lot of reaches go into the wood
Festival days of sacrifice and rituals
that many find disturbing
but Voodoo supreme leader called the
punctive disagrees
colonizes Marcus as fetish but Voodoo is
not all about worshiping dolls or
bloodletting it's not about magic voodoo
is a complete belief system that does a
lot of good things
believe the religion survived Decades of
European Onslaught and Will Survive for
many more centuries to come
foreign